as it turns out it may not have been the
best idea to put a 78 year old
dementia patient in the white house who
could have possibly
predicted that well anyone could have
and many of us did
we've only just begun to experience the
consequences
of having a mentally and physically
unfit person as commander-in-chief
the embarrassing display during biden's
first press conference on thursday was
the latest embarrassment
that he has brought upon himself and
thus upon upon the country
and it certainly won't be the last the
media is of course
making things as easy as it can for our
senile president by posing questions
like
and i'm not making this up questions
like are immigrants coming here because
you're such a good and decent man that
is only a slight paraphrase
here's how it was actually phrased let's
listen thanks so much mr president
you've said over and over again that
immigrants shouldn't come to this
country right now this isn't the time to
come
that message is not being received
instead the perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man is
the reason why a lot of immigrants are
coming to this country and entrusting
you with unaccompanied minors
how do you resolve that tension and
how are you choosing which families can
stay which can can go given the fact
that even though
with title 42 there are some families
that are staying and is there a timeline
for when
we won't be seeing these overcrowded
facilities with run by cpb
when it comes to unaccompanied minors
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whoever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
yes mr president mr president mr
president follow-up question um
you uh it strikes me that you're a very
good-looking handsome man
thoughts thoughts on that
our media holding feet to the fire as
always
but their efforts couldn't save biden
from himself
as he stumbled mumbled bumbled his way
through the short exchange with his
obedient press corps
at one point the president claimed that
he came to the united states senate 120
years ago
let's listen to that with regard to the
filibuster i believe
we should go back to a position of the
filibuster that existed just when i came
to the united states senate 120 years
ago
and that is that now
that claim is closer to the truth than
it ought to be
i mean it wasn't 120 years ago but it
was not far
from that uh his math is still a little
bit off the mark though and that was far
from the most alarming incident at
another point the president began to
answer a question trailed off
into unintelligible rambling stopped
abruptly
and picked up with a new thought here's
what that sounded like
i'm going to say something outrageous i
have never been particularly poor
at calculating how to get things done in
the united states senate
so the best way to get something done if
you
if it holds near and dear to you that
you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're going to get a lot done and if
we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh kim
well that was outrageous he was right
about that now here's the transcript of
that moment sometimes
i think it helps to to hear it again so
we can understand just how
incoherent it was he says i'm going to
say something outrageous
i have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done in
the united states senate
so the best way to get something done if
you if you hold near and dear to
to you that you uh um like to be able to
anyway i we're gonna get a lot done
now if this was the first time that
biden had
stumbled in this way we might just
assume that he didn't have enough coffee
that morning or he was especially
distracted for whatever reason but
this kind of thing happens all the time
not slips of the tongue but
divergences into full-on incoherence and
it's getting worse
remember it's only a few days ago that
biden proved himself incapable of safely
navigating a flight of steps
now he's standing on national television
claiming that he entered the senate in
the year 1901
it now seems to be a question not of
whether camilla harris will be the one
finishing out biden's term
but when exactly she will take over
another question
if biden becomes entirely incapacitated
assuming he isn't already at that point
will we be informed of that
when will we be informed how can we have
any confidence that they'll tell us the
truth about biden's condition in the
future
if they clearly aren't telling us the
truth right now
all of the ingredients for a
catastrophic constitutional crisis
are present they were already baked into
the cake the moment that a 78 year old
man was inaugurated
this this ought to be the last time we
allowed that to happen
in a sane country laws and amendments
would be passed to ensure that this does
not happen again
quite simply it is madness to allow a
man like this
to become president of the united states
leaving aside my personal and political
feelings about joe biden
i mean i wouldn't want him to be
president even if he was 30 years
younger admittedly but
there could never be a good reason to
put a person so
old into the highest and most important
political office in the land
even if biden were not already showing
clear signs of mental regression
it would still be the case that one in
seven people
over the age of 70 have dementia one in
seven
the percentages only get higher as you
get older and it certainly can't help
your case
if you happen to be in one of the most
physically and mentally demanding jobs
in existence
about two million people with dementia
in this country are age 85 or older
but there are only seven million people
total in that age bracket
what this means is that mental
deterioration is
is very common for older people and only
becomes
more common the older they get if a man
is elected president
at 78 again even pretending that he he
has his wits fully about him
at the point that he's elected there's a
very significant probability that he
will lose his mind
before his first term is completed it is
very
very probable if if he does not
you know lose only his mind he may
likely lose his life in the intervening
years as well the life expectancy
for a 78 year old man is nine years
okay uh wait so if you're at 78
most likely you've got nine years left
if not less
and that again doesn't factor in the
unique stresses and burdens of the job
they get to that life expectancy of nine
years for 78 year old people
but they're measuring this based on the
majority of 78 year old people who are
retired
and are living lifes of uh relative
leisure
we don't allow anyone under the age of
35 to run for president and i've rarely
heard anyone complain about
that age restriction in fact i've never
heard anyone complain about it
never yet the risks inherent
in having a decrepit president are much
much greater than the risks
of having a spry young 32 year old in
office
if we're ruling out the 32 year old on
the basis of his age alone
it doesn't make any sense that we refuse
to rule people out on the other end of
the age spectrum
there should be an upper age limit on
the presidency just as there is on a
lower limit
we could be generous so we could talk
about what the age limit should be
um we could be generous we could put the
cap at 75
you could go younger you could make an
argument for younger and this would give
every american 40 years
between 35 and 75 to take their shot at
the presidency
if they desire can't get it done in four
decades it wasn't meant to be go home
and play with your grandchildren
it'll be better for you it'll be better
for the country it'll be better for your
grandchildren
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content